the global society the landscape of our
global community is really changing
rapidly and there are trends that are
developing that I think they've embraced
and accelerated could have a profound
positive effect on the trajectory of our
global society and I think the open
source movement and data sharing I think
is a very very big part of that it's
important for organizations to have all
the pieces of puzzle especially these
are development organizations these are
Crisis Response organizations but we
have not to date really had a sufficient
effective means to share data and I that
I don't mean we have technical barriers
to sharing data we have cultural
barriers to sharing data there are a lot
of organizations around the world
including Crisis Response and
development and humanitarian
organizations that are reluctant to
share the real data that make that it
that enables true collaboration and I
think that's a mindset we need to get
around the other thing is there's a
difference between providing data and
providing data in a usable user-friendly
way that people can actually use for
good and so there are a lot of efforts
around the world to be able to take
particularly big data and to put that
into bite-sized bits to put that in in
something that's that can be used by the
public used by citizen scientists used
by governments to create good and I
think there's a strong move in that
direction but we've got a long way to go
one of the things that I think is really
going to affect our global society is
and one of the things that I think is
going to propel open-source and
transparency and data sharing is I
believe that true open collaboration
which requires all those things is going
to be a tremendous economic engine and I
think that those organizations and those
people and those governments that in
dealing corruption and Bill and
secretive dealing those organizations
that take an exclusively proprietary
mindset are gonna see themselves being
left behind and they're gonna have to
adapt and evolve and and take on a much
more collaborative and cooperative
mindset to be able to keep up with the
economic growth that true open
collaboration will bring and I think
this is a really significant trend you
know there's many problems that we that
we face as a global society you know
option for instance you know I don't
think we've had corruption probably
since the first transaction and I don't
think we're gonna be able to tackle that
head-on but we can potentially make
corruption obsolete by making it
irrelevant by making it be an
ineffective way to do business